le poser de gros problèmes aux
constructeurs qui ont été obligés
quelquefois d'importer des moteurs
essence de shin beth a importé des
moteurs essence de chine pour répondre
donc voilà le problème aussi c'est qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de constance dans la
durée sur les politiques publiques
je crois que c'est un constat un peu
sévère quand même parce que je crois que
en fait nous étions les champions du
monde du diesel en france avec le groupe
et ça qui était vraiment très très
performant sur le diesel s'est impliqué
aussi une filière diesel avec des
motoristes diesel qui sont quand même
beaucoup implantés en france
il faut pas l'oublier et donc
l'évolution où on le sent elle va aller
vers la vers l'électrique peut-être le
tout électrique j'en sais rien mais en
tout cas on va vers cela parce que
effectivement on a envie que le climat
où les citoyens vont poser directement
leurs questions aux sénateurs qui vont y
répondre et en direct et le goût ça se
passe quand ce sera tous les mercredis
en fin d'après midi
[Musique]
et c'est parti pour une nouvelle saison
d'on va plus loin sur public sénat du
lundi au jeudi en direct de 18h30 à
19h30 pour l'entretien du jour le match
les idées et le grand débat on reste au
coeur du débat sur public sénat
[Musique]
la matinale d'infos public sénat cette
année c'est le journal des territoires à
7 heures 30 puis à 8 heures après la
matière aux territoires d'infos et lavit
et politique
et enfin troisième partie territoire
sénat à votre tout nouveau rendez vous
sur l'actualité politique et parle